everyone thank you all coming I think
I'll start I'll start by making
emergency what I'm now telling this one
should we be required to evacuate the
building which is please need to build
upon that here is my exit there was one
fire exit in this room if you need to
evacuate the room do so but the glass to
the external fire escape staircase
please have both handrails in case the
stairs of weight loss typically if
anyone is unable to use the stairs but
they base it out other states in the
room or they go to the fire escape door
where they can be given a systematic
assembling point being the public car
park at the side of the Civic suite
please do not delay your evacuations
collecting belongings please do not
return to the building
commissions to certify council staff
please like this meeting will be organ
imported if I can ask you any magic cell
phones off please
Jim that might say number one which is
apologies for absence
we have apologies from counselor Brooke
way counselor mrs. Mason - counselor mr.
Mason and counselor mrs. Palin
videos
substitutes
treasury management
[Music]
so educated missus the customer
preferential strategy for their next
financial year and it's absurd to see if
your comments and approval prior to it
going to a full council on the 12th of
February as part of the budget report so
I think you'll be aware from previous
years that we are required to have in
place treasury management and capital
strategy this is actually the first year
that we're and the the new guidance has
come in to course from set fo which died
last year was quite us have a joint
capital and treasury management strategy
although we did actually have one in
place for the last year as well but the
purpose of the report is to sell our
wider and strategy for our investments
in light of their capital plans we have
open expedient
so yeah the report obviously sets out a
number of sections in terms of what we
classify it as comfortable as a council
how we plan to finance on capital
expenditure also our treasury management
investment strategy and our position in
terms of any commercial investments that
we might want to take a section one by
one officer also obligation to ensure
that the council officers have their
relevant religion skills or they quite
function of relations like well so in
terms of their substance ed their report
and I would just say that overall the
strategies will changed significantly
from the 1890s dashiki so it's
essentially the same strategic outlook
that we're facing the main updates are
in relation to the actual capital
program and we have incorporated the
planned investments around the asset
strategy which have been separately into
investment or
so the substance of that expenditure is
not anticipated to incur be encouraged
until 2021 onwards so it doesn't have
any direct impact on the 1920 pencil
forecast but it is something to bear in
mind the future because obviously a
substantial investment we potentially
will make as a council subjects are
being agreed at the Federal Council in
terms of my investment you know and
counseling to assets so that will have a
significant impact on our capital
program in a few years I agreed to go
forward but as the date of owning a
direct impact on one nineteen twenty at
the moment because we're not
anticipating any in the capital receipts
or expenditure to happen in the next
financial year I think it's already
being circulated but there is only a
slight sand errand as being picked up in
on painting 26 in terms of the castle
and financing requirement table so I've
circulated a revised version of that
table 'm why proposed to do is just the
inversion that goes to and it's going to
fall cancel our world with them submit
that amended version at the table but
essentially the 1920 forecast and the
original one wasn't feeding through
credit so it's basically each year has
been moved on the year and the 1920
meters being
incorporated so for the next and
financial year the new capital forecast
spend is four point seven nine million
in which a substantial amount is being
funded from our not desire so I thought
that would be financed by not deserve I
think about 500,000 pounds of that will
be from the disabled facilities grant
which is specifically or without them
but the fact that doing capital
improvements on the home individual
homes so that they're the terms of the
major financing streams that they have
to program next year
and then we do have applied revenue
contribution grow since their budget of
them just own 250,000 pounds as well so
you'll notice that the capital financing
requirement figure doesn't change here
one year so that's basically an
indication of our July interns or owners
little more costly only need to or over
the the next few financial years that's
why that that figure doesn't change year
on year so such an expenditure main
determinant here will be financed in
this room
reserves although new contributions
we're not anticipating any need to
borrow money comes program as it
currently stands
so yeah knock strategy reflects about
the we as accounts a while risk-averse
we're not we're not in support at the
moment but as we've said in our a again
as I said strategies to investment or
if there was any requirement for any
sort of short-term hiring for cash flow
purposes that Worman was required as
part of that program we would have to
subsequently bring the strategy back
back into a future meeting or wait till
the next financial year when this
strategy will be represented so to
change that to change that stance but at
the moment we as a council where we said
we're not going to be any more own
unless there's a change of policy as
part of this strategy yeah I was going
to say at this point there's a number of
recommendations that are reported at the
report so ultimately you're being asked
to yo no to the treasurer cap and trade
management's they've been included in
the relevant investment interim and
instruments indicators and delegations
within the report to know to come to
expenditure forecast which is what I've
just sort of run through into high level
in terms of all the plan to spend on
perhaps of over the next few years and
to no operational authorized limit for
external debts as they done in the
reports so at the moment a notional
limit because we're not actually raising
any Rory and I need to recommend the
contents of
stay tuned for counselling for
everyone's questions just a couple of
questions and the take new amendment
basically on under the nineteen twenty
thousand just out of interest
yeah the section 106 income yeah so I
can understand why that's not budgeted
what or isn't it amazing
perfect here's to kompis for that year
for 1920 would we not have any idea of
potential section 106 income I mean
large dr. Sears 175 yes
you say or would have been included yeah
so I think it's probable we will get
some the main source of their sexual my
sickness income we realized 1919 has
been through a realization of historic
and sort of right to buy housing things
that was aware with transfer housing
stalking them in the in the past we
still and liable to gain some of the if
any of those properties subsequently so
we actually get some of that back in at
the council in terms of section 106
income more generally obviously a lot of
the arrangements are in place are not
necessarily capsule in nature so they
they can be yes whatever contributions
can be a revenue or they can be a sort
of agreements inclined so at the moment
we have enforce a clear education of
what we could potentially get in 1920
but obviously we loved a that as the
year progresses and in fact official
changes will be back to the council by
having brought in an absolute substance
to it smoke -
just on that same table that same
quality I like that the capital groans
that was he says at 500 because as you
explained we expect tonight the reason
why date last year it was significant
was the reason for that
yeah big increase
that was actually their quality
improvement we got that we were holding
on behalf of the work that we are doing
with busting in Essex County Council so
that was saying yeah one of them right
in front 1.2 million so that's the
reason why it's substantially higher in
this financial year w Joseph going
forward only a couple of things thank
you which I really lost on page six
point nine six point five the casually
expenditure 2029 turn on standard reason
for what Jost during his long the impact
and fact expenditure for 2019 nineteen
is China's 3:103 he's showing elsewhere
was 273 one or just one people that was
an error or [ __ ] off one the money
anywhere it does look on your face fit
that I'm not sure why they so I will
turn that way if they is not playing for
the right figure either then I will and
read that but I don't immediately have
the answers while they don't do much
better now yeah each other yeah I'll
come for it interesting I just
Japan avoided him sorry man
thank you Kevin on that capital
financing table capital expenditure for
the very last forecast why is there so
much lower than all the previous years
and so I think the 2020 21 and 21 22
years that perhaps program is sort of
abnormally I've it that way as a result
of the asset and program that is being
built in so obviously every limited some
of those even even though it might not
happen
well I've built in the biggest I've been
approved by investment boards obviously
it hasn't been agreed by four counts at
this point but we've made the assumption
given that it's MDG is that that's our
best estimate of what will happen but
obviously we can remember the knife
whatever reason that program doesn't
continue but we bite figures in this
strategy of what's been agreed by us
with water so that does go in that they
are significant
in those two years and then after that
we expected to come down to sort of more
level process of Nexus anymore I said
development yes but we just build on our
own information at the time of all be
notice I've been
okay
hates that word brexit are you with
bricks it you confident that we are in
this respect in the best way you
possibly can yeah
you are take your plan apart and it's
being taken into consideration
yeah so it's obviously something we've
discussed with our Treasury man and the
buyers so I'd say in turn to the broader
business of breakfast the council there
was a former reporter went to the
council in December in terms of the
wider is the breakfast places but in
terms of specifically around treasury
management
I think the Linkara admires this is said
obviously it's very difficult to
forecast the impact because some some
analysts are saying it could have a
positive impact on the site so having a
negative impact so it really could go
either way so I think it's something
that we just have to keep watching
briefed on it's not something we can
model with any level of certainty in
terms of our investment returns but I
think we just have to be aware that
obviously if there is a shock to you
that to the system it could have an
impact on our own whatever returns but
our investments are or see with strong
and credit rating organizations and we
think that the place organizations
should have the resilience to do and
obviously those organizations aware that
and frankly coming so in in terms of how
we sort of deal with
micromanagement
investments as accounts or I think we
just have a missile awareness van
financial year end that we'll see we
want more we want you to do lots of sort
of movements are just around that peak
time until things are such dancer we're
probably at a tougher investments in
place over that period we're not going
to do is sort of dodging them and that's
an activity but yesterday we just really
have to keep watching brief and see if
and see what happens but we can't really
predict many certainty with which way
the markets tonight today I think
anything is also worth adding that given
the nature of the investments that we've
got if if the sort of companies involved
do go down we're going to be at the
bottom end of the people who've got
worries I have I think they'll be much
more significant things that are
affecting the nation and sort of taking
the money out and sticking it under
Sean's desk I think what we're doing is
as as wise and as prunus arrived here as
you quite rightly said no one really
knows and if we were to spend too much
time and money putting precautions in
place I think we could end up wasting an
awful lot of resource the environment is
just
no and you're second-guessing people
without natural and relaxed but it's a
second advice amazing things oh yeah I
mean if we were to be advised or
specific with Roxy witnesses and
mitigate that but I say they don't
really think there's a specific actions
that we can take I think that speech
within what we're saying although our
being has to do with the pretty raising
of Sean's discus thank you Jim
in view of the publication of what the
council is doing in the near future
these these figures would alter
drastically wouldn't they obviously
actually beyond beyond 2020 total things
would we be looking at a much more
favorable figures you can you just sort
of let know me know exactly what is your
well party the thing that I'm asking is
that with the full cast that you've
thought through on the future years that
would it would be quite a different
story in after 2022 what would you
imagine if the council was to carry out
these future I think you said the only
question is that wire twisting 25
22 two forecasts of its own speakers so
are we referring to their councils I
don't go around yeah passionately in
there is frightened yes yes yes I know
too much gas it gets a nice forecast the
fights are the best night information we
have an outline business case stage
which is what's going to be presented to
Council of 19 they are included in the
biggest as they also that boldly has
been ensuring that work would be in 20
21 and 21 22 which is why the statement
including the second one
expenditure from cost of code one - no
key operational and authorized limits
the external debt as they down at the
bottom
for is to recommend the context report
to full council with the amendments yeah
let's discuss
[Music]
20
yes so that's the only one that that
goes on the next one and these are the
two new ones number 190 the well holds
financial assistance policy degree
amendments relating to the removal of
Ming testing and specific circumstances
I'm told the two bits that they're going
to be moving testing on our work under
5,000 and home from hospital works and
then lastly 219 the environmental health
service plan for 2019-20
that's the annual one that always comes
out
just ask them to put it on it was going
to be coming sorry genocide I'm thinking
down there
I'm just wondering who's on this little
bit keeps kind of food you're on mental
health keeps going up as a very
high-risk toppings yeah yes that's it
sorry no fears what is just something
that they are Devas also did nothing
might be something we should concern
ourselves with they come up on their you
talking about sorry I just want to say
if it's been raised as a it came it
doesn't a definitely a high risk of
there's definitely a problem
they are possibilities my reasons are
I'll add it to the list
okay
[Music]
when next month is the community safety
can't be right no no in any purse yeah I
would imagine that he will just cross
out the ring
yeah the weights Louise will be
presenting we will have a member of the
place didn't recognize me
female the new barrel commander could
well be I mean somebody's new soldier
but I believe the new visit process the
new barrel come and visit visit lady I
think not they stick for you know
another by mind was mentioned last night
by somebody I had heard before is it you
said I can give my presentation well
here this is it'll be and he'll be a
report because it's round about the same
time as the Community Safety Partnership
set their targets I'm quite new to
review um do they just compiled a report
and give it to us what do we ask for
specific things to be
usually they compile it Evans's want the
CSP of doing what the targets are the
next years etc if there's areas that you
want them to focus on and cover
obviously it's got to be district-wide
rather than sort of town wise or
incidents around the report that they
will compare will be based on the police
data person where things that is being
given to the Associated Center
unfortunately we know that doesn't
always match what's actually going on
it's because people get back if there's
information that you want the camera if
you let me know
I'll make sure yeah and the member of
the place will not be information to
hang to answer your questions
what's a year-on-year comparison a few
key
indicate researchers and so should be
thank you
because if we give them ideas what we're
after yeah I think they'll come
questions in there all teams changed in
fact that she would be saw the drop
drivings up because that was never
actually something that they did I mean
is there a direct feel you can get or
travel beautiful truck use one of the
six things I mean I don't know under
health because it's how many people are
in the system and what they're being
reported these have mine even pops them
and after I'm dealing in the certain
area and my I did the Chairman from what
I understand is that they can only give
him give new details or what's been
reported not what we do because I know
there's enough a lot more going on in
Roth in white bars and negative woods
but I know there's a lot going on there
and it you know whether the priests
police we have it down as a crime or
crawling whatever thing is that they
report them but yes you're right cancer
reasonable like that there are other
things that are going on and I don't
know if they can actually give us the
form they're all of
and what they suspect what might be
probably suspect rather than what is
baby probably two of them yeah yeah what
we will just build my be repeated
cancers very loose energy um really they
eat they don't report based on what
their decree objectives are and they
won't even have any funding spend they
would do but they sewing your a bit
we're a bit then if they don't have you
on there is no be I'm guessing what
we're looking at is to see if they've
got the things yeah when I always look
to see if they've got the things on
there which I think are the problem in
my area that I cover on other areas and
whether or not they they could want it
to remeasure their medically to know
what they're doing is making a
difference there's no reason why after
the come and spoken to you you couldn't
decide to actually ask for more
information on certain area and ask them
that
or what do a piece of work on that I'm
just going to walk people race in my
area and one of the things I've had to
are some proper mentor social behavior
what they're doing about it is when
there's either theft from home burglary
theft from our building when she said
say Carter is different or theft from a
car how many of those are actually
followed up it was as percentage that
they don't even bother to attend and
perhaps also how many are resolved
which is very few on the phone making
that perhaps us what we can do this
thing's yeah I would want it to be a
fashion often are not doing nothing but
like you something if you're asking the
question is there more than we could be
doing as a council you know cameras can
be the benefits of taking a bit get
positive yeah
always be a bit cautious about bringing
them in here
no it's not gonna change in info for a
scarf and you know all he's going to do
is just upset religion do you know if
anybody rings in on me is it that one I
want system
it's that actually recorded yeah yeah
job about my dance about actually not
that gentleman you spoke to on Saturday
I did completely wrong
it's done the first time I thought I was
great but she came that's probably
something we can find out outside of
yeah we're just wondering if it's not a
little incident over that time it won't
get recorded willing the problem eights
yet encourage people as medicine number
101 if you report on line you get it
yeah I think one of the most basic
questions for the whole district is
manpower level if we find out there's
only two police officers operating the
whole that district front of it then
that's not good news
okay so we're taking classic white
that's wrong
well that's where that's the complete
area they can have each area and they're
mostly based there as well right up
anyway
yeah that's man power levels in
Colchester you've got any questions or
areas of concern an email you mean that
we can always put it to them if it's
relevant I think you know if they may go
to include it or they can certainly make
come better prepared business statistics
or answers if they're printing only
gonna be on
last year we a visit to tremens hall and
when we did we found quite a few things
that were not right we was unhappy with
and I believe that a lot of those things
have now been repaired is there any
possibility of going back to see what
they've actually done
could be also closer to make older
[Music]
one of most ladies I believe that they
into showers we're in an appalling state
and we complain the fire alarm
20:18 it door wasn't working and hadn't
been worked for a few years and the
police has been done there was the fire
exit
domes in the swimming pool which were
not working
another busy would be necessary but
perhaps AC we had a report in October we
do and at the time they said these
improvements were going to take place
I've just want to come up you know cuz I
like to say that I couldn't you know I
have been the true Clement sold twice by
quick but obviously just for a cup of
coffee because I was messing up but I
was in I asked at the reception this
distinct assembly but our representative
wasn't there for the very point that I
just made just have a quick look to see
what improvements had been done but I
think perhaps maybe we asked for an
update and or maybe ask people protocol
which I believe is castle with its maybe
if you can find them now if you want to
come in and just give us an update and
reassure members that
the students taken has been completed
and the 8hn metal if you want
calisthenic thank Gemma
what I understand is that from the
futuristic if you want to make an
appointment to all three of you can make
an appointment to visit to visit the
major centers that's both of the major
centers that they're around I will they
will actually accommodate you if there
is anyone that does want to do it I
wanted to come back with a read poll on
on that as you could do it if anyone
will stare down as a counsel remember
the public I think it's good that you
mention that they can do that and then
we can get updated officially from
offices so so are you saying I can just
go down there and say you have to remake
the photos okay I don't have a mic you
don't like that boy begins by being
raised on the website you can bring them
really much picture to make a German and
she was she I think it's just she I
don't know anyway yeah because they've
put in manager rounded John yeah because
now he's looking after the whole whole
lot in the whole lot yeah we're before
he was who's been important another
person because he was based it was jolly
major going on the manager reading I
think just keep rolling
she'll accommodate
yeah I was that die and I'll talk to the
manager tonight working area yes you can
like an appointment
when you clean you currently
refurbishment is still ongoing they've
done a lot of they've changed in some
areas done will they wait wait there is
but there's still work on going on the
shelves so he's humble
Thank You chairman I'm sorry or just
thinking of a number of area to possibly
our procurement privacy's I'm not clear
with their I don't make anybody else's I
know I wasn't selfish I want to be able
to go out for you know tender but there
are below a certain threshold you go out
to just quotes don't you now it's only
from somebody puts in crimes do against
the same people all the time or do we
circulate that do we review it do we
turn by local it depends on the amount
the procurement rules are in the
Constitution which give the levels yes
we would try and use local firms we can
yes I'm the larger contracts we
restricted because of you
then we have to come out and put it on -
there was a website yeah there's a
website I can contract find something so
there are frameworks as well for various
yeah the council's of thought so
rather than keep going here trying to
find difference at pockets
supplies to register beyond the
framework they get advice when a council
is asking for something because that one
I don't want to call smart more of the
officers but I don't smoke metal you
don't want they go to the same old table
all the time because they were always
getting that the same price rather
they're looking around walk a bit
differently you know different ropes
coming in they're not nowadays they have
to go there's a saying you have to get
three quotes but we
and we do yes we know which one was
cheapest the last time but we try and
see if we can get it cheaper from other
companies within I don't know to the
ones that will actually fulfill with
best value yeah well I'm usually you
know because pets family you names being
most economically advantageous tender
say they were charging more for
providing more apprenticeships in
district that we might go for that for
people that I stopped appearing as most
economically advantageous in there I do
number of keys I've couple canceled over
these never against the vendor don't
bring that up [ __ ] that I just thought
was that one because so and now I'm just
thinking the things that people raised
with me that we should be keep the cat